Halloween. Samhain. All Hallow's Eve. Whatever
you call it, it's known as the time of year
when the veil between the land of the living
and the spirit world is at its thinnest. It's
the time of things going bump in the night,
carving pumpkins, slipping on a rubber mask
and getting ready to terrorize the neighborhood.
Whether you celebrate by going door to door and
extorting strangers for candy, staying in
and watching scary movies in your pajamas,
or going out to wreak a little havoc
with eggs and rolls of toilet paper,
just about everyone likes to mark the
day with a little bit of spooky fun.
The folks at the SCP Foundation are no exception!
Sure, they see plenty of horrors in their everyday
lives, but that doesn't mean they've lost the
holiday spirit! Around Halloween, staff can
find Jack-O-Lantern shaped sugar cookies waiting
for them in the break room alongside hot cider,
and there is a yearly party in the canteen
with Halloween tunes, bobbing for apples,
and even a costume contest! But for some,
these festivities don't quite cut it.
They're not creepy, spooky, or ooky enough
to truly celebrate the scariest holiday.
By "some," I, of course, mean Dr. Jack Bright,
everyone's favorite immortal human consciousness
living inside an anomalous necklace.
Dr. Bright was determined to take last Halloween
up a notch, and he gathered his supervisors
together to pitch his latest brilliant idea:
a haunted house, open for one night only,
filled with frightening anomalies from the
SCP Foundation. His request for resources
and permission to put the haunted house
together were swiftly denied, but Dr.
Bright is nothing if not determined.
Without the use of official funds, he
began plotting. He tracked down a venue,
a large abandoned farmhouse a few miles away
from the Site, he found a discount Halloween
supply store, and he watched hours of crafting
tutorials on YouTube to put together the best,
the scariest, the most memorable house
of horrors anyone had ever seen.
He planned the launch of his haunted house
attraction to coincide perfectly with the
annual office party. While his colleagues were
busy dancing the Monster Mash and enjoying the
apple cider, Dr. Bright was getting ready to
open the doors, unveil his months of hard work,
and scare the pants off of any customers who dared
step inside. However, in all his preparations,
he had forgotten to spread the word to
the nearby community, except for an ad
he purchased on Instagram. So, when Dr. Bright's
House of SCP Horrors opened for business, only
three people were waiting to purchase a ticket:
Janie, Maddie, and Zach, a group of high school
sophomores looking for something to do before the
Halloween party in the woods later that night.
As the doors creaked open, Dr. Bright ushered
the teens inside with a wave of his hand. He was
dressed up as Dracula, complete with a cape
and a pair of plastic fangs. When he spoke,
he affected a comical vampire accent: "Velcome,
children! Prepare for nightmares that vill
last a lifetime!" He waited for his guests
to acknowledge his incredible performance,
but they just stared at him blankly for a moment.
"Um...are you done?" Janie asked.
Dr. Bright cleared his throat, suddenly
self-conscious. "Admission is five dollars."
The three teens shrugged,
and handed over the money.
"Enjoy! Oooooooooo!" He backed out
of the room with a ghostly wail.
"Ok...byeeee..." Maddie called after him.
"Follow me into the first room! Ooooooo!"
Dr. Bright's voice came from around the corner.
"I guess we just...go that way?" Zach followed the
voice, and his friends joined him, as they walked
into a makeshift laboratory where Dr. Bright was
waiting. The lights were dim; a steel table sat
in the corner covered in something dark, red,
and wet. In the darkness, a cloaked figure
moved about, his face a long, beaked mask,
his hands covered in thick black gloves.
"Welcome, new patients, to the lab of The
Plague Doctor!" Dr. Bright declared. Behind
him, SCP-049 was performing an experiment on
the remains of a cow. With the flip of a switch
on the wall, a flash of electricity crackled,
illuminating the room as the Plague
Doctor looked up to greet the newcomers.
"Oh, welcome! May I show
you what I've been working
on?" He held up a long, gleaming scalpel.
"Is that it?" Maddie remarked, unimpressed.
"I think that's it," Zach replied.
"Kind of boring," Janie sighed.
If he could, the Plague Doctor would
have frowned. "I am but a humble man
of science, doing my work. If that is not
sufficient for you, then I apologize..."
"It's fine, Doc, don't worry." Dr. Bright opened
the next door. "Follow me, and have your spines
tingled by the next terrifying chamber!"
"Ew." The group of teens laughed. Still,
they had already spent five dollars on
this thing. Might as well see it through,
and tell everyone at the party later about
this weird man and his awful haunted house.
Dr. Bright led the group down a long,
narrow hallway. It smelled of rotten
wood and mildew, the carpet squishing
unpleasantly beneath their feet.
"Keep an eye on your surroundings..."
Dr. Bright called over his shoulder.
"We might not be alone in here..."
Behind him, the kids rolled their eyes.
"Just don't touch the walls,"
Dr. Bright said, ominously.
The group followed him, not the least
bit nervous. It was a creepy old house,
but there was nothing in here scarier than
a cockroach. As Janie felt something crunch
beneath her shoe, she stopped to take a look.
"Ugh..." She groaned. When she looked up,
she noticed something strange. Black goo,
dripping down the wall next to her. "God
this place is gross." She grimaced. Her
friends turned to see what made her fall
behind, and their eyes widened.
"Janie..." Maddie's voice wavered
slightly. Zach pointed.
"Behind you..."
Janie spun around, and was confronted with
a horrific figure. SCP-106 was emerging from
the desiccating wall, smiling at her with a
wide, toothless grin, his flat eyes filled
with malice. She gasped, but then stopped.
"Oh, it's just an old guy. It's fine."
"Nice try, grandpa!" Zach laughed.
"Follow me, please! Move away from the
wall! Please!" Dr. Bright was beginning
to regret bringing SCP-106 into his
attraction. It seemed a bit too dangerous,
now that he thought about it. "Quickly!"
"Okay, what's next?" Maddie linked
arms with her friends, pulling them
after their incredibly cringe tour guide.
"Well, you're about to find out! If you can
handle it..." Dr. Bright opened a
door with a big sweeping gesture.
"Step inside...the kitchen. Of DEATH!"
"Ooh, what's for dinner?" Janie quipped.
"Doom." Dr. Bright grinned.
The visitors and their guide walked
into a dingy kitchen, rusty pots hanging from the
ceiling, a wood stove crackling in the corner,
something fuzzy, green, and unidentifiable
growing in the sink. The first thing that
greeted the group, aside from the smell of meat
sizzling in a pan, was the sound of a bellowing
male voice singing an operatic aria. Sure
enough, there at the stove, wearing a chef's
hat that appeared comically tiny on his massive
head, was a giant of a man, singing. He wore a
blood-stained apron reading "kiss the cook."
"Oh, welcome! Who's hungry? I've been cooking
all evening! It's an old recipe I learned
while studying under Julia Child at her
culinary academy, a truly famous dish. I'm her
nephew, you know! Fernand Child! I keep her
memory alive by preparing my favorite meals of
hers. Though I didn't use chicken for this one,
I selected a different protein..." The giant
man held out a serving spoon, shoving it into
Zach's face. "Want a taste?"
Zach recoiled. "No thanks,
man, I'm a vegetarian."
"Suit yourself, more for the
rest of us! Any takers?" Fernand offered the
spoon to Maddie, who shook her head. Then,
to Janie, who seemed to consider it for
a moment, but then turned it down.
"Fernand is what I like to call a
'humanitarian'," Dr. Bright quipped.
"Thank you sir, I do enjoy my charity work!"
Fernand saluted him. "Oh, and we do have another
guest joining us for dinner, correct?"
"That's right! Though she prefers her
meat rare. So rare, in fact..." Dr. Bright
grinned wickedly. "That it's still alive."
"I've set a place for her already!"
Fernand gestured to a small table,
where a plate held a large serving of raw
liver. Next to it, an open bottle of wine.
Behind the little group, a woman swept through
the door. She was beautiful, but eerie somehow.
Her eyes glinted with a feral cleverness, and
under her thick dark hair were a pair of fox
ears. A tail swished behind her as she walked,
and her fingernails were more like jagged claws.
"Did you start without me? How rude." Her voice
had an edge to it, the same vaguely menacing,
inhuman quality that hung over the rest of her.
"She's pretty hot..." Zach whispered.
"Shut up!" Maddie elbowed him.
"No, he's right, she is," Janie piped up.
The woman barely acknowledged them, instead
walking to her place at the table. She picked
up the liver in her hands, and opened her
mouth to reveal unnaturally sharp teeth. Then,
she dug in with the ravenous hunger of a caged
animal that had not been fed in far too long.
"Terrifying, isn't she?" Dr. Bright urged.
"Not really," Maddie shook her head.
"What else you got?" Zach
raised an eyebrow. Meanwhile,
the fox woman had finished her
meal and moved on to the wine.
"Can I get some of that?" Janie asked.
"No! No underage drinking in my haunted
house! Only! Scares!" Dr. Bright sputtered.
"Fine, whatever, just follow me."
He led the group onward, leaving Fernand and
the Polymorphic Humanoid to their strange,
cannibalistic dinner party.
"If you aren't in the mood for a meal, perhaps
you'd like to watch a little...television?" Dr.
Bright gave a villainous cackle as he threw
open the door to the living room. It was the
least eerie room so far, a standard living room,
if a bit dusty. There was an overstuffed chair, a
couch, a coffee table, a lamp in the corner, and a
vintage tv set plopped down in front of the couch.
"How do you all feel about
clowns?" Dr. Bright asked.
"Oh no, no, no, I hate clowns."
Janie's face went pale.
"It's gonna be fine." Maddie patted her shoulder.
"Not like it'll actually be scary," Zach scoffed.
"Don't be so sure. Check THIS out!"
Dr. Bright switched on the tv,
which began playing an episode of SCP-993,
Bobble the Clown. Unfortunately for Dr. Bright,
but fortunately for Janie, he had forgotten
that SCP-993 doesn't show its more upsetting
content to anyone over the age of ten. The three
teenagers immediately collapsed, unconscious.
"Oh dammit, oh no-" Dr. Bright scrambled to
switch the tv back off. As soon as the screen
went black, the kids sat up, disoriented
and rubbing their heads. "Sorry about that,
technical difficulties. I mean- Ooooooooo,
scary scary technical difficulties!"
The kids stared at him blankly.
"Um. Claudia, a little help here?"
The three friends looked around, expecting
to see someone else in the room with them,
but there was no one.
"Are you feeling ok?" Maddie
looked genuinely concerned.
"He's fine!" A voice piped up,
just behind her. "Are you?"
Maddie spun around, looking
for the source of the voice, but there was no
one there. "Oh, I get it, you've got a hidden
speaker in here or something, right?"
"Nope!" The mysterious voice laughed.
"It's just me. Hey, watch this!"
Suddenly, Janie's phone floated out
of her pocket, hanging in the middle of
the air as if held by an invisible hand.
"Rude!" She snatched it back.
"Pretty good. I almost didn't
see the wires," Zach smirked.
"No wires, kid, just me." A cushion flipped off
the couch on its own. The lamp tipped over on its
side. The tv remote careened across the room.
"Yawn." Zach rolled his eyes. "We came here
to get scared, not for basic magic tricks."
"You won't be so cocky when you see
the next room!" Dr. Bright grimaced.
"So show it to us, then." Maddie retorted.
"I will if you just! Go that way. Yeah, that
door. Open it." Dr. Bright sighed. "Blah blah
blah, welcome to the Infirmary.
Beware the patients, they bite."
Dr. Bright led the group
into a strangely bright room,
a jarring contrast to the rest of the house.
It was lit with buzzing fluorescent lights,
and contained absolutely no furniture.
As they walked in, they could hear the
rattling of chains, but they couldn't make
out the source of the sound at first. Then,
a figure lurched into view: it looked like a
person, but there was something horribly wrong.
Their skin was covered in patches of yellow,
gangrenous tissue. Their eyes were glassy and
vacant, and their mouth hung open in a slack,
empty expression. All along the
wall, there were people, chained
up and straining steadily against their bonds,
shuffling toward the group as they drew closer.
"Okay, zombies. Classic, I get it." Zach shrugged.
"They're kind of creepy..." Maddie shivered
as one of the creatures snapped its jaws at
her. It couldn't get close enough to take a
bite, but the intent felt real just the same.
"They're not real. It's fine," Janie gave
Maddie's shoulder a comforting squeeze.
"I'm afraid these poor souls are indeed all too
real." Dr. Bright's energy was restored as he saw
a bit of fear creeping into the group's sarcastic
demeanor. "Victims of a complex prion disease,
one with no known cure. Once they were infected,
they were lost within a day. Now, they're hollow
shells of their former selves, walking corpses
with only one goal: to devour the living."
"Sure, totally." Zach laughed, but his eyes
flickered nervously from zombie to zombie. The
room smelled like decay, thick and nauseating,
and these people didn't seem like actors...
"Next room, please!" Maddie's voice
shook, betraying her frazzled nerves.
"But I haven't shown you my favorite specimen
yet. Over here!" Dr. Bright led the group to a
massive glass tank, where something fleshy and
vaguely humanoid was crouching inside. It was
shaped almost like a person, but as if their
body had begun to melt. Skin had turned to
something soft, slick, and slimy-looking.
A palm slapped wetly against the glass,
and the group noticed that its fingers looked
webbed, excess skin growing between them and
stretching out, making the digits look more
like little tentacles than something human.
Then, it looked at them. Or rather,
it turned its face toward them. The
flesh had spread over the place where the eyes,
nostrils, and mouth should have been. Instead,
it was just smooth and blank
all over. For the first time
since they entered the haunted house,
the three visitors had nothing to say.
"This is a particularly awful disease. Highly
contagious, highly aggressive. Thankfully,
it's been contained...mostly.
Just don't tap on the glass,
you might aggravate him. Then
who knows what he'll do..."
With a creak, he opened the next door. "Shall we?"
The three teens nodded silently,
and, glancing over their shoulders
one more time at the eerie figure in
the tank, quickly followed him out.
"Enjoy the change of scenery!" Dr. Bright
commented, as he led the group out a side door,
back into the crisp autumn air.
"We're going out of the main house,
to the greenhouse over here. We could use
a little bit of nature, don't you think?"
"So, killer plants, or what?" Zach guessed.
"You'll have to wait and see." Dr. Bright stopped
at the entrance to a large glass greenhouse,
the glass dirty and opaque from years of disuse.
"Prepare yourself. It's a little swampy inside."
In the greenhouse, naturally, there were dozens
of different plants: vines creeping up the walls,
colorful flowers blossoming, moss hanging down
from the ceiling. The air was humid and hot,
a jarring change after the cool night
breeze just outside. The floor was flooded
with a shallow layer of stagnant water,
green pond scum resting along the top.
"These are new shoes!" Zach groaned as his
pristine sneakers disappeared
into the muck with a splash.
"Are there bugs in here?" Maddie winced.
"Oh, absolutely." Dr. Bright chuckled. "I
hope you've had all your shots, by the way."
"What?! What's that mean?!" Janie
demanded further explanation,
but Dr. Bright provided none. As
they trudged through the greenhouse,
the water grew deeper, climbing higher up
their legs until it reached their knees.
"Ugh, what's that smell?" Janie
pinched her nose with a grimace.
"Why don't you look over there and see?" Dr.
Bright pointed to an area just ahead, where the
water was rippling curiously, as if something was
just below the surface. A dark patch of tangled,
greasy hair slowly began to surface,
followed by a mottled green face. Large,
wide eyes stared at the group as
SCP-811 emerged from the water.
"You hungry?" Dr. Bright asked. She nodded
silently, looking intently at the teens.
"They're not for you, they're guests.
Here!" Dr. Bright produced a dead possum,
which he threw toward the swamp
woman. She held the carcass in place,
slowly melting it with the digestive fluid
that leaks from all of her slimy pores.
"If I get sick from this place, my mom will
sue you. She's a lawyer," Janie threatened.
"Let's move on then. We're almost at
the finale." Dr. Bright and the kids
left the swamp woman to digest her meal,
and headed back toward the main house.
"Follow me into...the basement.
Careful, it's dark down here."
Dr. Bright flipped a switch, and a single, dim,
flickering bulb illuminated the rickety
wooden stairs down into the blackness of
the basement. "Watch your step. Who
knows how stable these stairs are?"
As the group descended into the depths of
the house, they could hear the sound of
something sobbing, softly. Whatever it was,
it sounded positively heartbroken. At the
foot of the stairs, off to the side, they
could see a tall, thin, pale figure with
a burlap bag over its head. Its arms were
wrapped around itself, and it was shaking.
"So what, you'll pull the bag off and it's
something really scary?" Maddie guessed.
"Oh no, we won't be touching that bag. If you
value your life, you'll trust me when I say:
that's not worth it. He's plenty scary
without getting you all eviscerated."
"For a creepy basement, this is
pretty boring," Janie sighed.
Still, the group continued to follow Dr. Bright.
As they passed the Shy Guy in the burlap sack,
getting further and further away from the light
on the stairs, the walkway began to narrow. They
left the main room of the basement, and squeezed
into a tight stone pathway, one that forced them
to walk in single file, one right behind the
other. They couldn't hear the sobbing anymore,
couldn't hear Dr. Bright making cheesy ghost
noises or trying to build up the atmosphere. All
they could hear were their footsteps, their hearts
beating, and the sound of their own breathing.
Then, they realized...there had been
four sets of footsteps. But now,
they heard a fifth, coming from somewhere up
ahead. Whatever it was, it was getting closer,
and closer, and it sounded big. It sounded
like nothing they'd ever heard before. Just
when the tension was so palpable, wound
so tight they couldn't take it anymore,
Dr. Bright clicked on a flashlight and illuminated
the monster that stood just before them.
"RAAAWWRR! I AM RO-MAN!"
A massive furry creature stretched out its
arms, filling the chamber and leaving no
escape. The kids screamed, louder than they
ever had before, and ran back the way they
came. They sprinted up the stairs, back
through each room, and out the front door.
As they sat on the grass
outside, catching their breath,
Dr. Bright emerged from the house. He was
beaming with pride, and he was clapping.
"So, I did it, didn't I? I really scared you?"
"Are you gonna do this again
next year?" Maddie asked eagerly.
"I wasn't impressed at first, but you
really pulled it off." Janie nodded.
"It was pretty cool." Zach shrugged.
"You have no idea how happy I am to hear
that!" Dr. Bright smiled. "Unfortunately,
I'm not sure my bosses will let me
get away with this one again...Pretty
sure I'm in big trouble for doing it this
time. But you three made it all worth it!"
"Here," Janie reached into her
pocket and pulled out an egg.
"We were gonna use this later if
the place sucked. You earned it."
Dr. Bright wiped a joyful tear from his eye,
accepting the gift. "Happy Halloween! Now you'd
better run along to that party before it gets
too late. The creatures are getting hungry."
As he watched the three walk away, heading
off to make more memories, he felt a sense
of satisfaction. No matter what the bosses
did to punish him, or how many containment
breaches he'd risked that day, he knew he'd given
those kids a Halloween they would never forget.
Now go check out “SCP-823 - Carnival of
Horrors” and “SCP-097 - Old Fairgrounds”
for more terrifying attractions from
the world of the SCP Foundation!